.
Oh!
Ich wollte eigentlich mal
Pilot werden.
Aber da sich dieser Traum
nicht erfüllt hat,
dachte ich,
ich könne Modellpilot sein.
So bin ich auch Pilot
und kann ein Flugzeug fliegen.
Kilian ist 18.
Ich begleite ihn
schon seit zehn Jahren.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Als ich Kilian kennenlernte,
war er in der 2. Klasse.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Seid ruhig!
Zwei Jahre zuvor war bei ihm ein
schweres ADHS diagnostiziert worden.
Schau nicht in die Kamera.
- Doch, will ich.
Nein.
- Hör auf.
Schau nicht in die Kamera.
Nicht nur ist er dauernd
in Schlägereien verwickelt,
er ist auch ein schlechter Schüler.
Stets unkonzentriert und ablenkbar.
Darum stellt ihm die Schule
eine Sonderpädagogin zur Seite.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie man Orangensaft schreibt.
Orange...
- Orange...
Orangensaft.
- Mit g?
Orange...
Du arbeitest.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Kilian wohnt damals mit seinen Eltern
und seinem kleinen Bruder
in der Innerschweiz.
Weg.
- Hey.
(Frau) Nein, Kilian.
- Ich bin der Filmstar.
So nicht. Er darf auch.
- Ja.
Kilian war von Geburt an auffällig.
Er konnte
keine ruhigen Spiele machen.
Dinge, die andere Kinder
aufgebaut hatten, machte er kaputt.
Aber nicht, weil er das wollte,
sondern weil er seine Kraft
nicht dosieren konnte.
Er übertrieb es und machte sich so
unbeliebt bei anderen Kindern.
Dort, beim Sozialen,
merkten wir es v.a.
Im Restaurant oder beim Einkaufen
rannte er immer herum.
Wir merkten: Es läuft anders.
Darf ich auch einen Stecken nehmen?
Aus diesem Grund sind seine Eltern
mit ihm aufs Land gezogen.
Hier kann er sich austoben,
aber das nützt wenig.
Als Kilian sechs ist, ist seine
Mutter mit ihren Nerven am Ende.
Vom Vater
hat sie wenig Unterstützung.
Wir haben Homöopathie ausprobiert,
Schüssler-Salze, Kinesiologie
und andere Therapieformen.
Dann sagte unsere Ärztin ganz
vorsichtig, es gebe noch Ritalin.
Das war wirklich
unser absolut letzter Anker.
Wir machten uns
eine Nacht lang Gedanken:
Sollen wir, sollen wir nicht?
Wir sagten uns als Eltern:
Wenn wir es nicht einfach mal
vier Wochen ausprobieren,
werden wir nie wissen, ob sein
Leidensdruck nicht kleiner wird.
Seit zwei Jahren bekommt Kilian
36 mg Concerta pro Tag.
Ich finde es gut, dass ich es habe,
sonst schlage ich immer.
Und das möchte ich nicht.
Ich möchte
nie wieder schlagen müssen.
Hallo.
- (Frau) Hallo.
- Hoi, Kilian.
So, wie geht's? Hoi, Kilian.
- Gut.
Hoi, Daniela.
- Hallo.
Die starken Medikamente
haben Nebenwirkungen.
Kilian
muss regelmässig zur Kontrolle.
Er ist klein und dünn für sein Alter.
Wie ist es mit dem Appetit?
Hunger hat er prinzipiell nicht so.
Am Mittag isst er einfach.
Er isst wenig,
aber er isst immerhin.
Aber am Abend, wenn das Concerta
nachlässt, isst er.
Das ist super. Toll, Kilian.
Und das ist auch wichtig.
Wir haben die Dosis ziemlich erhöht,
weil er selbst erst dann gemerkt
hat, dass es ihm besser geht.
Auch die Lehrer haben gemerkt,
dass er seine Leistungen
mit der hohen Dosis
viel besser umsetzen kann.
Wir haben zwischendurch versucht,
auf ein anderes Medikament
umzusteigen,
weil die Dosierung sehr hoch ist.
Das war aber leider
nicht sehr erfolgreich.
Der Junge steht vor dem Übertritt
in die 3. Klasse.
Die Schule macht ihm Sorgen.
Was ist es denn,
was dich beschäftigt?
Hm ...
Wegen dem Englisch usw.
Wegen dem Englisch?
- Usw.
Was meinst du mit dem Englisch,
Kilian?
Dass ich beim Englisch
nicht mitkomme und so.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Die Situation verschlimmert sich.
Mit den Klassenkameraden
hat es schon wieder Streit gegeben.
Mit dem Schulstoff
kommt Kilian nicht mehr nach.
* Bellen *
Er kommt total fertig von der Schule
nach Hause und ist oft krank.
Hoi, Mami.
- Hoi, Kilian.
Ging es?
- Ja.
Sali. Du kannst sie mir geben.
Oh, ist die schwer.
Ging es am Nachmittag?
Du warst ja so müde.
Hausaufgaben?
Äh ...
- Das Diktat üben?
Ich glaube, ich habe keine.
Hast du keine?
Wahrscheinlich das Diktat üben.
Nachher essen wir Zvieri.
Er hat einen sehr grossen Druck, und
es ist ihm einfach nicht mehr wohl.
Einnässen, erbrechen, nicht mehr
essen, nicht mehr schlafen können -
daran sieht man,
dass das Kind starken Druck hat.
Es ist für ihn
nicht mehr auszuhalten.
Über den Hausaufgaben
bricht er fast zusammen.
Erfolgserlebnisse hat er kaum mehr.
Können wir?
Die Sätze schreiben wir später,
Kilian. Wäre das okay?
"Ehrlich".
Okay? "Interessant".
Seine Mutter glaubt nicht mehr,
dass eine Sonderbetreuung
innerhalb der Regelklasse
die richtige Lösung ist.
Wir Eltern wären froh,
wenn wir ihn in eine Rundumbetreuung
geben könnten.
Das bedeutet, in eine Sonderschule,
damit ihm wohler ist.
Denn so, wie es jetzt ist, haben wir
Angst, was daraus entstehen kann.
Kann er Depressionen
oder Angstzustände entwickeln?
Wie sieht es aus
mit Schulverweigerung?
Diese Sorgen trägt man mit.
Der Druck ist ihm einfach zu gross.
Wie lange er durchhalten wird ...
Wenn du dir wünschen könntest,
etwas zu ändern,
was würdest du dir wünschen?
Ähm ... schöner schreiben und so.
Würdest du dir nicht wünschen,
nicht zur Schule gehen zu müssen?
Das würde ich mir nicht wünschen.
Es ist wichtig, zur Schule zu gehen.
Man muss,
auch wenn man nicht möchte.
Man muss zur Schule,
man muss lernen.
Denn sonst
kann man später gar nichts.
Dein wichtigster Wunsch wäre,
schöner zu schreiben?
Bald danach wird Kilian tatsächlich
in eine Sonderschule umgeteilt.
Fünf Jahre vergehen.
Als ich ihn wiedersehe,
hat er ein neues Hobby
und wird
intensiv therapeutisch betreut.
Fast ein Rückenflug.
- Das könntest du mal probieren.
Aber du hast wohl noch etwas Angst.
- Ja.
Er übt mit seinem Psychologen,
wie er sich besser konzentrieren
und kontrollieren kann.
Er hat sich besser im Griff,
die Frustrationstoleranz ist besser.
Wir üben jeweils,
cool zu bleiben,
wie ein Pilot, der das auch muss.
Das hat er intus.
Das hilft bei Streit
mit seinen Freunden.
Ich versuche mich immer
so lange wie möglich zurückzuhalten.
Aber es ist schwierig,
nicht auf Provokationen einzugehen.
Oh, geil.
Geh etwas hoch, für den Looping
brauchst du mehr Höhe.
Der 13-Jährige hat mittlerweile
zwei Schulwechsel hinter sich.
Sogar aus der Sonderschule
wurde er rausgeworfen.
Gerade hat er an einem neuen Ort
mit der Oberstufe begonnen.
Medikamente nimmt er immer noch.
Morgens nehme ich
eine weisse und eine rote Kapsel.
Das hält bis um 18 Uhr.
Ich nehme sie um 6 Uhr
und um 18 Uhr hört die Wirkung auf.
Ähm ... Ja.
Aber das ist für mich
nicht schwierig, es ist Alltag.
Den Vogel nicht beachten.
Seine Mutter ist optimistisch,
was seine Entwicklung anbelangt.
Whoa!
Ich habe das Gefühl,
er wird immer selbstständiger.
Den Schulweg meistert er allein,
er steht morgens auf,
nimmt seine Medikamente,
er frühstückt,
geht pünktlich aus dem Haus.
Er strukturiert sich in
gewissen Abläufen komplett selbst,
macht den Weg in die Therapien
selbstständig.
Ich würde sagen, es geht ihm gut.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Das schaffst du, das schaffst du.
Aber die sozialen Probleme
sind geblieben.
Nach zwei Monaten ist Kilian
schon wieder aus der Schule geflogen.
Schon wieder
hat er sich mit Freunden geprügelt.
Als Erstes habe ich nur geweint.
Ich hätte nicht erwartet,
dass ich gleich
von der Schule fliege.
Aber so ist es jetzt halt.
Seit zwei Wochen
ist er allein zu Hause.
Niemand weiss, wie es weitergeht.
Sein Bruder ist in der Schule.
Er hat weder soziale
noch schulische Probleme.
Aber für Kilian sind die Tage lang
und ein bisschen einsam.
So allein bin ich gar nicht,
weil die Katze da ist.
So habe ich auch jemanden.
Die Katze kommt immer mal wieder
ein wenig zu mir.
Oh, du Arme.
Ich kenne sie schon,
seit ich ein Baby war.
Sie ist unglaublich wichtig
für mich.
Ich würde nie allein sein wollen.
Ausser wenn ich wütend bin,
dann muss man mich allein lassen.
Denn dann muss ich herunterfahren.
Seine Mutter
sucht eine Anschlusslösung,
muss um die Kostenübernahme
durch den Kanton kämpfen
und macht sich natürlich Sorgen
um ihren Sohn.
Er ist nicht mehr
im sozialen Umfeld.
Es geht ihm sicher nicht gerade gut.
Man vermittelt ihm ja auch
das Gefühl,
dass es nirgends mit ihm geht.
Das macht es nicht einfacher.
Aber er hält sich
an die Regeln und Strukturen,
die ich zu Hause gebe.
Aber er ist sicher auch froh, wenn
er wieder in ein Schulsystem kommt.
Es ist ihm schon auch langweilig.
Whoa!
- Kilian.
Ich musste schauen, wie hoch ...
- Was sagte ich vorhin?
Nach drei Monaten zu Hause
darf Kilian endlich
zweimal wöchentlich
in die Nachhilfestunde.
Ursula Schärrer
hat ihn schon früher unterrichtet.
Es gäbe noch
eine andere Möglichkeit.
Sein grösstes Problem ist Mathe.
Das flasht mega.
- Genau, darum machen wir das.
Kilian, genau darum.
Ich wollte schauen,
ob du das kannst.
Tack.
Ich muss die suchen ...
- Noch einmal.
Vier mal acht ... acht ... vier ...
Acht ... äh, vier, acht ...
Vier, acht ...
Fünfz...
Bisher sehe ich,
dass er bei den Basics,
also im Hunderterraum, plus, minus
und über den Zehner, Einmaleins,
so im Bereich Ende 2. Klasse steht.
Ja.
Die Diskrepanz zwischen dem,
was Kilian kann und können müsste,
ist sehr gross.
Es stresst mich auch, jetzt,
wo ich in der 1. Sekundarschule bin.
Es stresst mich total.
Denn ich weiss: 1., 2.,
3. Sekundarschule, das geht schnell.
Ein Jahr vergeht schnell.
Ich bin manchmal total gestresst.
Ich komme einfach nicht weiter,
habe keinen klaren Kopf mehr.
Es gibt auch Tage,
an denen ich schnell geschafft bin.
Ich werde müde und kann nicht mehr
denken, mein Kopf ist nur noch leer.
Dann habe ich keine Kraft mehr,
weil ich einfach gestresst bin.
Kilians Mutter
hat alle Hebel in Bewegung gesetzt.
Sie lebt inzwischen von ihrem Mann
getrennt und arbeitet Teilzeit.
Nach vier Monaten hat sie endlich
eine Lösung für Kilian gefunden.
Einerseits bin ich sehr happy,
dass er wieder in eine Schule,
in eine strukturierte Sache
gehen kann.
Andererseits ist es schwierig,
denn es ist eine Sonderschule.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, nur
unter verhaltensauffälligen Kindern
ist nicht der geeignete Ort.
Er muss jetzt
den Lernstand aufholen.
In einer öffentlichen Schule
funktioniert das nicht.
Er ist überfordert vom Lernstoff.
Ich hoffe v.a., dass er
eine dreijährige Lehre machen kann.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das würde er schaffen.
Aber er muss den Lernstand haben.
Das ist jetzt wichtig.
Weil die beiden Sonderschulen
in Luzern voll sind,
wird Kilian in eine Sonderschule
im Kanton Zürich eingeschult.
In der Gruppenschule Thalwil hat man
viel Erfahrung mit ADHS-Kindern.
Kilian wird eng geführt
und hat praktisch eine 1:1-Betreuung.
Und wie heissen die,
die du eingezeichnet hast?
Voll geil! Dünn.
Kilian,
ich habe eine Frage gestellt.
Es macht halt so viel Spass.
Du machst jetzt Geometrie.
Ich erkläre dir gerne Aufgaben.
Hast du hier wieder
eine Symmetrieachse gefunden?
Ich ... glaube ja.
Ihm gefällt's.
Es ist viel besser geregelt.
Und man hat nicht so viele Räume.
Man muss nicht immer
hinauf- und hinuntergehen,
sondern ich bin immer
in denselben Räumen.
V.a. bin ich öfter hier oben
und nicht unten.
Das ist hier viel besser.
Und es macht auch mehr Spass.
Ich möchte hier einfach nicht
von der Schule fliegen,
weil das die perfekte Schule ist.
Ich möchte hier bleiben
bis zur Berufswahl.
Der Wunsch ist gross,
dass es diesmal klappt.
Aber gleich zu Beginn
gibt es schon wieder Streit.
Begleitet wird Kilian
immer noch von seinem Psychologen.
Du musstest dich sehr beherrschen.
Du wolltest
und musstest dich zusammenreissen,
damit du keine gröberen Dinge tust.
Das war damals dieser Stresskuchen.
Dieser Einstieg war sehr schwierig.
Erstens aufgrund
der schlechten Vorerfahrungen,
quasi eine Angst,
was an der neuen Schule passiert,
ob das wieder passieren kann.
"Jetzt darf kein Fehler passieren."
Er war also einerseits
sehr unter Druck.
Andererseits war alles neu,
eine neue Klasse.
Alles ist neu und ungewohnt.
Es ist ein Neuanfang, ein Übergang.
Das ist für Kinder mit ADHS
immer schwierig.
Das alles hat Kilian
in eine grosse Krise gestürzt.
Er hatte schwere Angstzustände,
Panikattacken
und konnte nicht mehr schlafen.
Ich war so am Ende und so fertig,
dass ich ...
... auf den blöden Gedanken kam,
mich umzubringen.
Ich musste Roland,
also Herrn Abegglen, versprechen,
dass ich ... mich nicht umbringe.
Gut, und das gilt?
- Ja.
Sag mal, wie wichtig
war deine Mama in dieser Zeit?
Sehr wichtig, denn ...
... sie half mir viel
und hatte Verständnis dafür.
Ja.
Ich schaff das.
Ich schaff das. Ich schaff das.
Drei Jahre noch bis zum Ende
der obligatorischen Schulzeit.
Und ... Kilian packt es.
Kurz vor Schulabschluss
treffe ich ihn wieder.
Solch extreme Krisen wie damals
gibt es keine mehr.
Das habe ich nicht mehr.
Gar nicht mehr.
Ich merke immer stärker:
Ich schaffe es.
Ich kann es auch schaffen,
wenn ich will
und mich zusammenreisse.
Wenn ich mich bei der Nase nehme,
schaffe ich es.
Manchmal muss man halt kämpfen,
um etwas zu erreichen.
Kilian ist ruhiger
und geduldiger geworden.
Aber er nimmt immer noch jeden Morgen
54 mg Concerta.
Du musst es schon andrücken.
Ich muss jeweils am Mittag
ein Ritalin nehmen.
Ich denke jeweils selbst daran.
Jetzt in den Ferien
nehme ich am Mittag keins.
In der Schule schon - immer Montag,
Dienstag, Donnerstag, Freitag.
Aber am Mittwoch nicht.
Da ist es nicht sinnvoll.
Da bin ich auf dem Nachhauseweg.
Zu Hause brauche ich es nicht.
Was wollen wir nachher machen?
Ich muss mein Flugzeug einstellen -
wegen der Sensibilität.
Trimmen? - Ja, wegen
der ... Er geht nicht ganz hinauf.
Die schwierigen Jahre haben die
beiden Brüder zusammengeschweisst.
Bis du 16 bist, musst du
so was oder so was trinken.
Nein.
Es gibt Zeiten,
in denen wir uns streiten.
Aber es gibt auch Zeiten, in denen
wir uns richtig gut verstehen,
wo wir zusammen spielen
oder etwas machen können,
ohne ein einziges Mal
Streit zu bekommen.
Das sind die richtig schönen Zeiten.
Seid ihr fertig mit dem anderen?
- (Beide) Ja.
Und zieht er noch vorne hinunter?
Auch Daniela ist erleichtert,
dass es endlich besser läuft.
Als es in der Schule ruhiger war,
merkte ich:
"Ich kann wieder atmen.
Ich habe auch ein Leben."
Ich konnte mich schon zurücklehnen,
aber sobald irgendein Funke kam,
dass es nicht läuft, war ich gleich
in einer Angst und Not.
Denn ich weiss, was es heisst,
eine Lösung suchen zu müssen.
Kilian, mach etwas schneller.
- Ich mache so schnell ich kann.
Eine Lösung suchen.
Genau das steht jetzt wieder an.
Eine Lehrstelle
ist noch nicht in Sicht.
Daniela findet Kilian dafür
noch zu unreif
und hat ihn deshalb
für ein 10. Schuljahr angemeldet.
Er braucht diesen Rahmen
einfach noch, diese Begleitung,
diese Unterstützung,
er braucht einen geschützten Rahmen.
Das ist bei ihm einfach
noch deutlich zu spüren.
Dafür braucht es eine andere Stelle.
Allein aus der Sonderschule heraus
sind auch die Lehrbetreibe
nicht immer bereit,
die Schüler zu nehmen.
Sie machen Aufwand -
und das verstehe ich.
In der heutigen Arbeitszeit
ist das schwierig.
Darum muss es begleitet sein,
sodass der Lehrbetrieb entlastet ist
und er trotzdem Erfolg haben kann.
Er. - Ah, er?
Ich habe schon dich angeschaut.
Ich wollte schon mit dir zocken.
Zwei.
- Schon wieder.
Kilian hat immer noch grosse Mühe
mit sozialen Kontakten.
Das Kinderspital Zürich hat ihn
deshalb auf Autismus abgeklärt.
Ich wäre froh, wenn Sie
noch mal zusammenfassen könnten,
was Sie bis jetzt mitgenommen haben.
Der IQ war - so viel ich weiss -
bei 83.
Das weiss ich.
Und aus diesem Testergebnis heraus
haben Sie mir empfohlen,
eine Autismus-Spektrum-
Störungsabklärung zu machen.
Die Gründe,
warum wir daran gedacht haben,
sind einerseits,
dass Wechsel Ihnen Mühe bereiten.
Und dass vielleicht manchmal
das Gefühl für Nähe und Distanz
zum Gegenüber fehlt.
Darum haben wir
die Verhaltensbeobachtung gemacht,
den sog. ADOS.
Ich möchte es gleich vorwegnehmen:
Er erfüllt die Kriterien nicht
für eine Autismus-Spektrum-Störung.
* Daniela atmet auf. *
Gut.
Das ist schon mal gut.
- Finde ich auch.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt:
Wenn wirklich Autismus herauskommt,
warum habe ich es
nicht früher abgeklärt?
Ich hätte mir Vorwürfe gemacht.
- Das verstehe ich.
Kilian hat seine Schwierigkeiten.
Das weiss er selbst. Das wissen Sie.
Aber Sie haben das
wirklich super gemacht.
Mit den Schwierigkeiten,
die Sie hatten
und die Sie als Mutter hatten ...
Und jetzt haben wir
einen so tollen jungen Mann vor uns,
der auch etwas
an sich selbst verändern möchte,
der bereit ist, uns zu helfen,
sich zu integrieren, das ist toll.
Einerseits bin ich froh darüber,
dass ich es nicht habe.
Andererseits
wäre es auch nicht schlimm gewesen.
Denn ich wäre immer noch
derselbe Kilian wie immer gewesen.
Drei Monate später.
Kilian darf in der Stiftung Brändi
eine Woche als Schreiner schnuppern.
Es gefällt ihm.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich feile und schleife gern.
Ja, das macht mir Spass.
Endlich darf er arbeiten.
Das tut ihm gut.
Im 10. Schuljahr hat es
wieder Mobbingprobleme gegeben.
Kilian hat die Schule abgebrochen.
Kilian, geht's?
Ja, ich muss es nur
weiter nach hinten nehmen.
Die Lehrwerkstatt Brändi
ist spezialisiert
auf Jugendliche mit Problemen.
Etwa ein Drittel der Lernenden
hat ein ADHS.
Mit der Bandsäge nicht.
Aber dort weiss ich, wie es geht.
Das müssten wir zuerst anschauen -
wegen der Sicherheit.
Das grösste Problem ist,
dass sie abgelenkt werden.
Eine Gefahr besteht auch
bei der Arbeitssicherheit.
Sie arbeiten schnell,
wollen etwas abschneiden
und senken die Haube nicht ab,
sodass etwas passieren könnte.
Man könnte sich
einen Finger abschneiden.
Das ist zum Glück noch nie passiert.
Die Jugendlichen durchlaufen
einen mehrstufigen Eignungstest.
Es muss ganz flach anliegen.
Ich lasse Sie machen.
Ein erster Schritt
ist eine dreiwöchige Abklärung.
Dort schauen wir,
wie das Vorstellungsvermögen ist,
ob das räumliche Denken
funktioniert.
Und wir testen Mathe.
Gewisse Kopfrechnungen
muss man beherrschen.
Wenn man ein Mass falsch eingibt,
ist es zu klein oder zu gross.
Das sind keine guten News für Kilian.
Das Rechnen.
Dort habe ich Schwierigkeiten.
Aber die dreiwöchige Schnupperlehre
verläuft ganz ordentlich.
Acht Monate später
kommt Daniela mit
dem ersehnten Couvert nach Hause.
Es ging gut.
Ich komme
bei den Aufgaben nicht weiter. - Ah.
Der Vertrag.
Kilian kann im Brändi
einen zweijährigen Vorkurs
für eine Anlehre machen.
Lies mal vor.
Das ist die Krönung.
Klar, wenn er fertig ist, noch mehr.
Aber immerhin ein Schritt näher.
Das ist grossartig.
Darum bin ich so ungeduldig.
Während des Gesprächs,
als mir gesagt wurde ...
Mir kommen die Tränen.
... er bekomme einen Vertrag,
dachte ich mir,
dass es sich gelohnt hat,
dranzubleiben.
Es war brutal,
alles alleine zu organisieren.
Nebenbei
musste Geld verdient werden.
Dann der Haushalt
und der Alltag mit den Kindern.
Ich hatte viele
weinende und schlaflose Nächte.
Ich musste oft
mein Budget neu berechnen.
Ich habe nachts über Schulen
gelesen, weil ich da Ruhe hatte.
Es ist sehr anspruchsvoll,
das alles zu organisieren.
Für mich ist es auch ...
... etwas ...
Moment.
Es ist sehr wichtig.
Ich stelle mir immer vor,
dass ich den Olymp erklimmen möchte.
Ich möchte zu diesen Leuten gehören.
Jetzt bin ich nahe dran.
Erst mit abgeschlossener Ausbildung
und einer Festanstellung
ist mein Ziel komplett erreicht.
Willst du mal schauen?
- Ja, gerne.
Auch die IV
hat das Setting akzeptiert.
Sie hat viel geleistet.
Ich bin auch stolz auf sie.
Und sie ist ...
Es gäbe keine bessere Mama.
Und ...
Wir kämpften auch gemeinsam.
Sie musste aber am meisten kämpfen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ist es eingestellt?
- Ja.
Noch nie hatte Kilian eine so
unbeschwerte Zeit beim Modellfliegen.
Oh.
Sein Psychologe ist zu
einem väterlichen Freund geworden.
Endlich läuft's.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Der geht ab wie eine Rakete.
Ich probiere immer alles.
Wenn ich es schaffe,
gibt es mir ...
Dann ist das für mich
ein grosser Erfolg.
Egal, wo ich Erfolg habe.
Alles, was ich erfolgreich tue,
bereitet mir Freude.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ende gut, alles gut,
könnte man meinen.
Aber das Leben steht nicht still.
Daniela packt. Sie zieht um.
Ich ziehe in eine grössere Wohnung.
Kilians Weg zum Bahnhof
ist dann kürzer.
Jetzt sind es fast 2 km,
danach noch 500 m.
Er arbeitet den ganzen Tag.
Er hat wenige Ressourcen, morgens
und abends noch 25 Min. zu gehen.
Ja.
Ich freue mich auf die neue Wohnung.
Sie ist grösser und ... anders.
So weit, so gut.
Aber in der Zwischenzeit
hat sie auch eine weitere Diagnose
vom Kinderspital bekommen.
Und die
ist alles andere als erfreulich.
Bei Kilian wurden nochmals
alle grossen Abklärungen gemacht.
Neben ADHS
hat er noch viele andere Sachen.
Probleme mit dem Darm.
Oder ein zu kleiner Kopf,
also Mikrozephalie.
Mit dem Kinderspital in Zürich
wurde geschaut,
ob es sinnvoll ist,
einen Gentest zu machen,
um zu schauen,
ob bei den Chromosomen alles stimmt
oder ob es dort
Auffälligkeiten gibt.
Wir mussten acht Monate
auf das Ergebnis warten.
Dabei kam heraus, dass Kilian
einen Chromosomendefekt hat.
Auf dem zweiten Chromosom
fehlt ein Stück.
Das nahm mir die Hoffnung.
Die Perspektive
wurde mir quasi entrissen.
Ich brauchte einige Tag,
um das anzunehmen.
Da brach innerlich
ein Kartenhaus zusammen.
Kilians Hirn wird sich
nicht vollständig entwickeln.
Das bedeutet auch: Er wird nie
ganz ohne Hilfe leben können.
Er braucht in gewissen Bereichen
Unterstützung.
Gerade bei Bankangelegenheiten,
Behördengängen.
Betreutes Wohnen
wird mal ein Thema sein.
So selbstständig
wie andere Jugendlich mit 18
wird er wohl nicht sein.
Ich möchte keine weiteren
Abklärungen und Diagnosen mehr.
Es reicht jetzt. Es ist genug.
Er soll jetzt
einfach mal Kilian sein.
Kilian, der eine Lehre macht,
eine Schreinerlehre.
Kilian, der happy ist.
Aus seiner Perspektive
ist er nicht unglücklich.
Ich kann nicht beschreiben,
wie es sich anfühlt.
Endlich kann ich eine Lehre machen.
Ich bin gut gestartet.
Ja. Es läuft.
So entspannt
habe ich Kilian selten gesehen.
Der neue Bescheid
perlt irgendwie an ihm ab.
Jetzt wissen wir, dass ich das habe.
Das macht mich nicht besonders.
Also ...
Was soll das mit mir machen?
Ich kann jetzt arbeiten.
Da hat nicht ...
Es ist nicht mehr so wichtig.
Die Arbeit ist mir wichtiger.
Und vielleicht trägt auch noch etwas
anderes zu seiner guten Laune bei.
Kilian ist zum ersten Mal verliebt.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
M. Gassner, E. Graf, D. Zacheo